all right we have a dw exclusive for you
now
thousands of athletes officials and
reporters traveling to china for the
upcoming winter olympics risk having
their online communications hacked
through the official app for the event
that's what internet security
researchers from the organization
citizen lab in canada are warning after
an investigation into the my 2022 app
and dw has exclusive access to that
report now chinese authorities have
asked everyone taking part in the
olympics to install the app at least two
weeks before traveling to beijing it is
aimed at tracking and tracing for
coronavirus but it is an all-round app
for the participants so they will need
it to
register health data and to check in at
competition venues they can also use it
to check weather reports and to chat to
others who are also taking part in the
game
[Applause]
and dw's internet security expert oliver
lino has been looking through the
investigation he has more on this
exclusive story for us oliver tell us
more about what citizen lab has
discovered here
yeah the the app has a security
vulnerability uh in the encrypted
communication so in detail it is about
the proper verification of ssl
certificates
and because of this weakness our hackers
can still more or less easily
private data
for example the passport data
audio messages from the the chat
function that is included in the app and
but also the health data such as the
vaccination status can be leaked
and i understand there are also concerns
about chinese authorities having access
to the information that uh could be
hacked here so what exactly would
authorities be looking for
yeah maybe they they look for their for
for private communication for example
they are interested in and but they have
also included a censorship
list in this app so there's a file that
is called illegal words and
this has find out the citizen lab but
there has not been able to find any
evidence that the list is actively used
in the app
but there are more than 2000 words in
chinese and and simplified and
traditional characters
and also in tibetan and in
and for example you can find
the word the term nu
for holy quran
and i think the unanswered question is
what such a list has to
do within an app for the olympic games
okay so we're talking about a
vulnerability in the app and this list
of terms that could possibly be censored
i mean oliver is this surprising we do
know that china has hosted previous
olympics like in 2008
yeah of course china is a state of
surveillance this is known
it's a country of digital center
censorship or even the bbc and real dw
is blocked in in the country on on
internet and via satellite
um but this is in china and uh so the
olympic games are are in the bubble so
it's a special area for for the athletes
and for for all the participants and i
think they don't expect such a
surveillance there and what the citizen
lab has find out is much more so they
find the learner vulnerability uh that
can be used from hacker so from from
third parties and additionally the
censorship list
i got the impression that that many uh
of all the participants are not very
well prepared for this event in terms of
digital safety and the citizen depth and
research ngo has to come with such a
research
which could probably the job of national
security authority authorities or the
national olympic committees
dw internet security expert olive olino
speaking to us thank you so much for
that reporting
thank you
and we do have more details on the
citizen lab investigation on our website
dw.com